[Music]
who the F is a la after years and years
of unanswered questions
there's never tell you you never know so
much patient you know I would tell you
more tonight is the night that we find
out who ad really is yes here's
everything we know about the PLL finale
I would say pay a lot of attention to
specific details little details that
this is going to be so much fun the
viewers will know before the girls do I
was scared I was going to be
disappointed but it's very good I was
throwing off yes I wasn't expecting it
when you start to realize that there
were hints and trails and everything
just kind of clicked for sure you will
remember it forever
epic shocking yeah I was like wait why
how does it impossible all engrossing
lovely heartbreaking is so
astronomically well done I know the fans
have been through a lot
from the past seven seasons but I'm
telling you it will all be worth it I
came out of left field so I hope that
they show that with you I you can
probably figure it out if you look close
enough honestly it's like I don't
couldn't be a better understand it's
beautiful it it's funny it's bittersweet
with Spencer it is going to be a
resolution different character there's a
happy ending there are a lot of
flashbacks in the finale every question
is going to be answered so the reveal is
very important but then the
understanding of it is equally as
important so that's why it's two hours
so both the fans and the players can all
process at all at the same time thank
God after seven years you're like Oh
finally
you